那我們今天要來講我們的這個直播
深度解析隔日沖啊
好 那我每天做短沖交易齁
其實有很多標的
也沒有到每個標的啦齁
就很多標的
我們有很多標的呢
都會跟隔日沖有點關係啦
齁 那隔日沖呢
隔日沖的標的就是活潑
齁 他們標的呢 通常都是波動很大
齁 像昨天齁
昨天
這個
標的裡面齁
這我來看一下
昨天標的我有存檔一下
昨天標的呢有很多檔呢
都是這個今天波動很大
像我今天我做一檔
當充啦
我覺得我做的還不錯
欸
找一下我的
這邊在
今天有做一檔
就這檔
6117的銀廣
小哥跟他Toyz
不會啦
不可能
我不可能跟Toyz一樣
Toyz太厲害了
重點是Toyz他都會講比較實事的東西
那我們
是處於比較財經類的
那我們也沒辦法
對於實事的東西
這個評論太多
那今天我主要就做銀廣啊
各位來看一下銀廣
那銀廣呢齁
銀廣他昨天有很多格衝啊
各位看一下這邊齁
銀廣啊像今天群經鼎
群經鼎今天呢他就這個賣了一千多張
他就是屬於一個比較大型的格衝
那這種比較大的格衝齁他就會讓盤中的波動很大
各位你看一下拉上來擊殺
哇拉上來擊殺
你看這波動超大
那這種波動很大的齁他的政府就很大
給各位看喔
他的政府啊
評價葛日聰對決奢華葛日聰
我們這個都是
比較奢華的
因為這個弄下來齁
弄下來的其實還蠻高的
報酬率還不錯捏
這個我今天做這檔賺多少錢
我看一下
我來看一下今天做這一檔
應該有兩個戶頭
大概賺了十幾萬有啦
今天光做這一檔因為今天的政府很大今天政府很大我跟各位講 今天真的沒卷我做的這一家呢 沒有卷
所以今天做的有點
有點謹慎
我們今天做的很謹慎
就是來回做 唉唷沒有
今天沒賺那麼多
今天是合起來賺10級
不過今天這一檔
這檔加當中手續費
折浪的話應該是賺
四五萬
哦四五萬
哦
我們
哇招君說
我的刀手機都是沒有啦
也會有付的啦
沒那麼囂張
沒那麼囂張說都是正
那給各位看哦像今天
哦哇昨天這個
早早去做
昨天呢
功課沒有
應該說這個盤頭功課沒有做很多
我就直接看
這個當沖繩手裡面的標的
直接看當沖繩手裡面的標的
然後呢
看了幾個標的
我覺得今天還不錯的是
我有幾個標的今天都沒做
都沒做
因為我最近對於
第一天拉漲停很多隔日沖的
我隔天完全不想去
不想去玩它
不會很想去玩它啦
來看一下這個合一
合一呢他是昨天主頭買標的
主力大買 投信也大買
像這種隔天
這個主力有可能繼續買
投信可能繼續買
那即便他會有隔日充的話
你要空這種標的
我勸你還是別空
因為你空這種標的你會很難做
你看這盤中被嘎到不要不要的
可能會嘎到快停損
所以這種標的呢你最好是不要碰
然後呢你要碰像剛剛講的銀廣
銀廣那個已經很多家都沒券了
所以呢你要空的時候
你可能你的停損呢
可能要設在5%以上
可能5-6%
5-6%以上你才能空
不是不是不是才能空
5-6%以上你就不要空了
5-6%以上你可能準備要停損
所以我今天這一檔是做得很小心
我大概是等到
這個比較後面才做
像這個點有稍微
這個點
這個點有做到
這個邊有做到
但是停損呢
就會
守得謹慎一點
你不能去守掌停板停損你守掌停板停損會很恐怖很有可能你會補不到那這個就很多隔日沖的標的
其實
其實很多隔日沖也不代表隔天一定黑K
但是有些隔日沖隔天黑K起來
那個幅度是超大
那個幅度超大
所以呢
這個做隔日沖標的股票
我們來看一個東西
我看一下,找一下我的欄位
來看一個東西啊
叫做
政府
這邊
來來來
來看一下
你看一下這個格衝標的啊
這個富橋
富橋是昨天已經
這格衝出場
那今天他的政府有到10%
那下都呢昨天就說他的政府很大
結果今天還可以從
那這個銀廣呢
銀廣就是我們說他政府會很大
然後到8.4%
所以我今天我有做到銀廣
我今天主要是做像銀廣
今天做哪幾大
我想一下
今天有做銀廣還有做見準
對今天有做見準
見準的政府到4%
4%
4%這個齁
這個也是
有做到
這4%就是我們所說的盤中手牽手盤後下毒手
沒錯啊
見準呢他就符合這個
盤中手牽手盤後下毒手
那這個標的呢
他是在這一天下毒手的啦
這一天
這一天我們特別幫他做雷手撕啊
盤中手牽手盤後下毒手
那這種只要下毒手
隔天幾乎都是開滴啊
隔天開滴
然後或者是直接
這個開地走地然後鎖跌停
以前長崗工很多齁
因為他下的這個盤後賣的張數還沒有很大
還沒有很大因為沒有那個量讓他賣
假如在這一天盤後有很大張數讓他賣齁
我看隔天大概率容易跌停
那他這一天呢他掛了2100張
就只中了700多張
可能有人抽手吧
這個就是盤
盤中手牽手啦
但首先走在这里已经出量了
所以他应该在这边
我觉得这
这根
这一段是原妇道的
原妇所了原妇道原妇道了原大吃了原大吃了原大後面又到原大後面又到所以這些呢都是
這個
盤中守前守盤後下毒守的案例
那這種案例呢
他隔天就容易開低
結果他隔天還真的是開低
隔天開低
然後呢集拉我空
這檔我有小做一點
那今天有拉到盤上
這一根呢他有被那個
那個什麼
被 AI 帶動嘛
你今天 AI 很強啦
你今天 AI 很強
所以呢做完
今天 AI 很強 後面就整個
整個殺下來
那整個殺下來也帶動了
見準 見準也是被
帶動到後面整個殺下來
殺下來 那這個其實也
應該有些隔離衝啦 我們來看一下
今天有沒有隔離衝落跑掉
你看這裡
有啦
元大就賣掉一些
元大在這裡倒盤後沒倒掉
趁著今天倒掉
今天有賺錢了
所以這種隔日沖呢
他今天都會
不是隔天賣
就是在隔天賣
隔隔天
那有的凹丹哥會
隔隔隔隔隔了好多天
來看一下凹丹哥
對
凹丹哥啊
來看一下我們上個禮拜所講的
欸 啊 華東啊
喔 來看一下華東
這個凹丹哥出了沒
欸 出了出了
漸漸快 都快被他出完了
凹丹哥
凹丹哥就是群衣金鼎啦
在這邊有賺不出
然後搞到現在還沒出完
還沒出完齁
目前庫存還有4200張
群衣金鼎還有4200張
等到
各位啊
等到華東
只要等到華東
群衣金鼎賣完
那華東大概就可以買了
我是這麼覺得
因為最大賣壓結束
華東就是在
這個等群衣金鼎賣完
因為群衣金鼎他就每天賣
每天撐每天賣每天撐
他就每天一直撐著
撐著
撐住不賣
他在高檔被管錢哥到啊
凹丹哥
高檔被管錢啊
還有國票安和啊
喔 那個還有隔日沖啊
喔 隔日沖
盤中手牽手
喔 那隔天怎麼樣
隔天有一家隔日沖跑了
另外一家還不跑
這是最傻的啦 我跟各位講
隔日沖最傻的就怎麼樣
最傻的隔日沖就是
你跟別人都隔日沖 結果人家跑了你不跑
而且還有賺錢喔
有賺錢你不跑是怎樣
你看這裡
你看 凱基台北買3300張
他隔日衝他隔天就跑掉
結果凱信台北跑掉群英精靈不跑
不跑就算了還
還大買
但不曉得他在想什麼
不跑還大買
不跑大買的結果其實會蠻慘的齁
那這一天還好滑都沒繼續跌啦齁
我把它用20天我們來算一下
算精靈哥賠了多少
20天精靈哥賠了1500萬
扣掉手續會單跟當沖齁齁
其實...應該也賠了快兩千了啦
走續費跟交易稅也蠻貴的嘛
這個扣一扣也賠了快兩千
那這個其實隔衝你...你該跑就跑嘛
你不跑凹也可以
但也不要凹太久好不好
不要凹太久
剛剛有人講台藥,我們來看一下台藥
台藥看一下那個永林哥
哇靠
永霖凹擔戈
永霖最愛凹的啦
來來來
台耀卡一個永霖大將喔
2000張卡在這裡
卡在這邊
喔呦
所以台耀明天應該
波動蠻大的來來記錄一下
這個明天可以記錄一下喔
來我們把明天自選股
先來看一下台耀
明天之前股肯定是有台耀的嘛
還有今天這個盤中一直出量的
還有一檔是今天盤中一直出量
我還是不要講啦
因為今天這檔比較小字
台耀很大字啦 台耀又有期貨
所以台耀明天
這個各位你
你不要去沖現股啦 台耀沖期貨就好了
台耀沖期貨就可以了
因為要期貨一個TICK
一個TICK就賺1000了啦
你用当中神器去抓一个Tick两个Tick都很好抓啦當中神器買盤捷徑那個永林哥假如要出的話那一兩個Tick很好抓
來來 各位這個線上的
線上的高手們
你有沒有看到什麼
哪一個有凹單的
可以幫忙 可以分享一下
分享一下 我們今天這個
純粹來講隔日聰
看有沒有什麼凹丹的隔日蔥
還在的
我們可以分享一下
因為有時候凹丹
凹一凹大家都忘記了
像這個台藥
還有啦
滑東也還有
滑東凹丹哥也還沒出來
有一支粗量喔
今天漲停板有一支盤中一支粗量
那我一直看到盤中一支有幾百張的
這個到貨
他是鎖漲停的
鎖的後面鎖的很吃力
那有隔日蔥的股票呢
通常隔天波動都很大
都很大
好 那我們每天呢
我們都會跟各位
給各位看
我們今天當中的哪一檔股票
那有時候
這個有記得的話就會給點位
我們給點位是說
事後給啦
我們當然是不可能事前給
事前也不曉得他隔天怎麼走
我們事後給點位
就是說事後給各位看
我們的點位是坐在什麼位置
坐在什麼位置
好
欸
1815,1815今天已經結束了
來看一下1815
今天啊,今天這個格衝很多
今天是這個齁
1815也太刺激了齁
昨天
昨天我有衝富橋
昨天衝富橋還玩得蠻大的
昨天富橋我有賺到錢啊
昨天富橋有賺到錢
然後呢,這個想不到今天開了大獎
昨天這種開法多好啊 對不對
昨天這根大黑K的話我就賺翻
結果昨天沒有 我昨天殺了又殺 殺了又辣
昨天你不要看這十字件 十字件難做得要死啊
各位你看一下昨天
殺下去補完 補了之後又往上拉 拉到這邊又往下殺
哇昨天這個是超難做的啊 就是你在那邊
建著部位殺下來之後 那反彈你還會建點部位 這邊又被嘎
嘎了之後又再往下殺
所以這個齁
這個就是
呃昨天看起來是比較呃看起來以為很好做結果沒有很好做波動還是蠻大的啦反正我們挑的標的齁
隔天波動都很大
這至少3%啦
至少3%
啊你不要以為3%股票很多呢
其實3%的股票其實不多
我們來看一下齁
那個可當充標的
我們找可當充標的就好了齁
我們看政府
政府呢有一堆啊
有一堆都什麼
都幾乎沒政府
這邊有一堆沒政府喔
我們把它拉到一半
拉到這邊大概是一半
這邊啊
這個郵標大概是一半
有一半呢大概
都在1.5%
政府在1.5%欸
各位你看
這邊政府是才到1.5%而已
你看你不要以為這個政府很大喔
71.7到72.8
這才一塊錢而已
這政府1.5%
1.5%當初我們都不愛玩啊
1.5%有什麼好玩呢
你1.5%那個
國家抽0.2%
國家這個
稅收跟手續費抽0.2%
那你只剩1.3%
也就是說你所賺的啦
因為1.5%
你也很難
這個空到最高買在最低嘛
所以呢你賺的錢呢
你賺的錢1.5%我們算一半啦
你可能賺0.7好了
那你賺0.7
0.7扣叫0.2
各位你的成本0.15是交易稅嘛
然後呢手續會打折
所以各位的成本約莫在0.2到0.3之間
那政府1.5%你賺0.7
手續會跟交易稅收了0.3
你剩0.4%可以賺
可以賺
呃啊這個還是方向要做對
方向做錯更慘
哦更慘哦
好
欸等一下
大安哥材料在敗家貓的幫忙
欸真的是敗家貓哦
我們以前常常說這個
這個
家裡齁當沖不要養貓啊
養貓呢在盤中當沖記得把它關在別的房間啊
我说记得把关在别的房间不要
不要那个
啊
这个这这这材材料是哪一天我看一下材料是哪一天材料是有一天很刺激的喔欸是哪一天 這一天啊欸不是不是這一天 材料是哪一天
這一天
大一個 11月2號
材料那個也是很刺激 這邊這邊
敗家貓
我是覺得這個貓的機率還蠻大的
第一個貿易機率大啦 因為那個
499跑去按
這個蠻好玩的 就是499跑去按的啦
這是499去按
那499去按還誘發了停損單你知道嗎
還誘發了
追價
追價單跟停損單
499去按 那按完之後 哇
這個大安兄還是蠻有尬值的喔
這個不凹單的喔
不凹單的
各位你看不凹單的
買上來之後立馬自己砍下來
喔有沒有看到
喔真的很厲害
喔很厲害
好
這個
僅如你的問題我就不方便在直播回答了
直播我們講的太細
太細
主力都在聽了就好了
我們就不大回答
太細的問題
好 那你看喔 你看
哇 你看這個波動超大
自己買上來 自己砍下來
立馬3000萬不見嘛
你自己看一下
3000萬不見
買金價
賣金價972
3000萬不見
敗家貓
貓按了之後自己停損了
好一隻破彩貓
好
好 這個這個破彩貓
等一下 我
我 我先跟我朋友講一下
欸
朋友要找我 喔這個
我的朋友要幫我復健
復健一下我的脖子
好
那為什麼不鎖死呢 欸 問得很好啊 為什麼不鎖死
這個問題呢
嗯
他可能
他可能看到貓案了之後呢
趕緊
這個下意識反應趕緊停損喔
嗯
呃...他為什麼不順勢往上鎖呢
這我也不知道
那搞不好順勢往上鎖,這當天搞不好變大賺
這也很難講
不是主力打來啦,沒有啦,沒有主力打來
我們有些東西我們還是不要在直播講得太細
直播講太細喔,有覺得會破功
有些,有些你講太細,這...破功
畢竟我們在市場上,也算是量也打得蠻大的齁
至少PR,我跟各位講啦
無論如何我的打單在自然人裡面
我的PR值
PR值那個量啦
我說那個量
我的量一定是PR值99以上
就99點多啦
我的量啦
在自然人裡面
肯定是啦 絕對是
百分之百是
假如是100個人一定是
在贏過99個
那1000個人應該是贏過999個
那可是呢在1萬人他就不見得
1萬人我就不確定
反正我們的量是玩得很大
所以有些東西我們還是
在公開媒公開地方啊
公開直播還是不要講太多
公開直播講太多
其實以後那個整個會變化
教學小細點
我講自然人啊
自然人就是要排除掉法人嘛
排除掉法人
還要排除掉
呃有些是做程式單的
齁因為有的程式單呢他也玩得很大
也不曉得他在幹嘛
齁
那這個我們的當衝齁
其實大部分
都會從這個
呃我們當中大部分都會從
從隔日衝的名單去找
齁那所以我們今天呢就要教各位齁怎麼看隔日衝
齁怎麼看隔日衝
好啦那一開始呢
來來我們先把這個弄一下
一開始呢請各位加一下這五個虛化項
粉絲團,Lite,官方社團,YouTube跟Telegram
那粉絲團呢會貼全證主力進出狀況
官方社團有
這個交易的知識YouTube教學影片
Lite偶爾發
Telegram每天公告都會發
哦
趙華有說台股我現在小哥的話
沒有啦哪有那麼厲害
那我的IG是Warrant-LB
哦
我是全證小哥
觀看人數破1000 按讚破300 我們送金瓶娃娃
喔 最近破1000有點刺激跟各位講你們 我們都講那個怎麼賺錢的方法對不對分享賺錢的方法也看的人也少
這個
你看我們還是比不上人家講大馬的
講大馬 10萬人看
有沒有看到
10萬人看
我們講賺錢的方法
接下來700人看了
你看這麼少
700人看
好啦 沒關係啦
這個有些東西
知道了還是不要太多
啊 所以各位
這個年間700人看
哦 那
那我
可以講的我就講
哦 那太細了我還是不要講
啊 那關於人數破
按讚破300
嗯 破1000我們送
按讚破300我們也送
好
那直播注意事件呢
請將YouTube畫質
這個調到最高
哦 跟老高衝突此間
老高你可以
看重播嘛 對不對
老高又沒有那個
對不對
又不急 對不對
我們的這個賺錢比較急好不好
賺錢比較急
直播版權署 理財寶跟獎人所有
請不要錄製參謀
YouTube 畫質比較不必
可以轉到YouTube觀看
這個
不過說真的
我們的
呃 畫質呢
就是1080P啦
我們並不是奢華的2160P
首先看那個
哇 這久妹的道歉影片
還是2160P的咧
吼
這個道歉影片還是走高規格
好
直播提到標的呢
僅供教學研究 物作下單參考
更非投資建議
投資又很大風險
沒學過可別下單
好啦 來看一下
宣的這個
這個得獎的留言
皮已經訂閱兩年多了
喔 真是小哥最佛系的
光問題問道保衡
這樣超
我現在每天錄屁
我們有錄影分兩段
喔 來給各位看一下
好,我们录影呢
每天的影片呢分两段
今天的影片还没出来
今天影片还没出来
来看一下这个昨天的影片
昨天影片是这样
昨天影片呢,我们影片有两段
这是第一段
第一段呢有7分57秒
啊,这个是第二段
第二段呢是学人的问题
回答了13分30秒
13分30秒
所以呢這邊每天錄影20個
啊
看小哥Live都是有深度的對沒有錯我真的這麼覺得啦你追蹤小哥算是有深度因為我們的東西都要動腦
要動腦
偶爾看看不用動腦的
就是開開心笑
我就吃點瓜
也不錯啦
至少是紓壓嘛
但是我們的東西呢
要動腦
喔
昨天還有開斗內喔
哇塞
拉高
道歉的影片還開斗內
喔
這個這猛喔
欸我們的影片沒開抖內喔
各位
我們現在
你現在看直播沒有開抖內喔
我們沒有開啊
我們直播是沒有開抖內的
所以各位
呃
幫我按個讚好不好
按個讚就好
我們不用開抖內
我們沒開抖內
喔
我們幫我按個讚
喔 按個讚
喔
這已經久沒了
久沒了不知道喔
這個
搞不好今年尾牙有機會看到他
有機會看到他再來問他
我不知道會不會看到了
不知道
反正我們這個尾牙我們常常會看到一些Youtuber
只要有機會看到他再來問
嗯
動腦賺錢比花體力賺錢來得好
對啊
真的
動腦這個人
人齁這個
欸年紀大了齁這個
年輕的時候可能是用體力賺錢啦
那年紀大了我們就是用
用腦賺錢
那更
更勝者齁 就是你可以用
那個
用什麼賺錢 你可以用錢來賺錢
好 那用錢來賺錢呢 我給各位看一個東西
我先把該遮的遮一遮
好
這是我今天收到的一張
基金收益分配通知書
那很多人跟我做同樣標的的
你今天可能有收到這封信了
有沒有看到
什麼的尾牙
什麼尾牙 就是那個
Placeplay的尾牙
那基金收益分配書
欸 這裡面呢 我就有這個
這次的基金收益了
原大投資及公司債
那我以前呢 就跟選講
你有空呢
你大概就可以去存一下
好啦 這是這個基金收益分配書
我大概給各位看一下
我先遮一下
遮一下我的個資啊
來來來
你有空呢 你就可以這個給各位看 這邊這邊應該都這了吧這邊
這個是基金收益分配書啊
你有沒有看到數字
就是
長線的嘛
長線
長線我們那時候就跟各位講說
你在
00720b
那時候
我上趙華的節目的時候
剛好是上禮拜三嘛
上禮拜三
有特別
看不到數字喔
看不到數字
看不到
好啦 我再借近一點
給大家看
對賬單
看到沒
在靠近喔
好 再移開
有沒有看到
靠近一點
好 可以一看
就這樣
應該看得出來
那時候上禮拜三在
在這邊呢 我們就有跟學生講
這裡
上禮拜三的時候
太久了
有看到了
應該看得清楚吧
我剛剛自己看都看得清楚
好啦
這跟各位講 我不只做短線啦
我們還會
做長線
那長線呢就是
其實在第一檔我們就
一直在加碼
這個00720B
我一直在加碼00720B
為什麼要加碼它 因為第一個它的
它的殖利率還不錯
殖利率不錯
各位你看一下
它的配息啊
0.49餒
你看配息最近這都差不多啊
0.49 0.48 0.50.49
然後呢前幾天已經最低點來到了30.75啊
那這次呢是
配完息之後
配完息之後30.75嘛
那最近已經反彈到32.59
那你假如在上次
配息前啊這是配息前
配息前你買到現在也填了啦
也填了0.49
反正就是
你每買一張
我在剛才有說過
你有錢你就存一張
那你存一張呢
相當於你每天呢
你的這個
現金流就多5塊
因為他的配息都不會差太多啦
所以呢
你就相當於你每天多5塊的這個收入
那當你
你這個買的越多張
有一天呢
你買的張數他的配息超過了
你的
日薪
就是你每個每天的日薪
你每天你的錢
超過你的日薪
你就可以考慮你要不要來
退休
因為我是覺得
人生
除非你假如工作工作得很痛苦
你還是找一天好好退休
像我是覺得工作還蠻有樂趣的
所以我到現在也還沒有全退
但是我就慢慢的來存一些
存一些這個
長線的標的
那我們除了做長線以外
其實我們就是
所有手上的標的
OS是長多嘛
長多呢搭配短空
短空就是這個
隔日沖裡面去找標的來做
那找標的來做
這些呢他的勝率會比較高
反正就不能凹單了
然後呢你要避開很多很危險的標的
有隔衝也不代表一定跌啦
有隔衝最近有些股票
都是連漲兩天在跌
好 那我來看一下
第二个
感谢小哥不离轨道客交的葛兰币招式
看几乎现行加上筹码胜率真的高了许多啦
真的
多中都有的配对交易很难在市场上毕业
的确
谢小哥全方位独门监控
其中一项功能来跟单短杂
也有不错的加太金
流水墙中有大金额的全镇进货出
在捷径短多后短空
这个还不错
恭喜你
那另外一個這個
謝謝小哥批評分享及無視的直播教學
千年一種教學方式好讓心就熟
我說一兩多更感謝小哥
敬禮推薦的台股時光機
有時候對個股操作錯誤的時候
就會用復盤方式來檢討自己
操作失敗的原因喔謝謝小哥不常識用自己的實戰
今天帶來學員一起成長助小哥身體健康
好恭喜得到三眼關的娃娃
好那我就
有人問
00679B12傳盤
那我真心跟各位分享
啊 這個
你又寫我呃 第一個喔美債的話呃 債券呢 我比較喜歡公私債啦我比較喜歡公私債但是美債比較安全嘛
但它的殖利率就比較低啊
美債殖利率比較低
你自己看嘛
殖利率就比較低
他這個也接近30塊啊
他現金股利就是0.29嘛
就比較低啊
公私債比較高啦
但是萬一公私有問題的話
公私債他是有很多家公司啦
那當然是公司倒了也會影響到他的禁止嘛
那美債倒的機會比較低嘛
那美債是比較安全
但殖率比較低
那我比較喜歡的是
這個殖率比較高
那稍微有點危險
稍微有點危險
好
長存喔
啊長存你就可以買點
像目前
債券最近有漲啦
那
這個假如他有在稍微跌的時候
我是覺得過幾天可能又會稍微跌啦
有稍微跌的時候
你在考慮要不要再去買啦
那...對阿
我是不想買美工債
我是想買公司債啦
那我也買了很多啦
這個...各位你有看到配型
就知道我買的張數很多了
那就這樣
因為這個...其實有這些張數喔
其實後來我每次都在想
那我持有這個部位 有這些張書
那我就好好的
這個有一天我可能就會退營江湖了
也不看盤了
每天就到處遊山玩水就好了
為什麼 因為只要你賺的錢
每次住飯店的時候我都會想
這飯店一碗可能六千 七千 八千
或者是貴一點可能到一萬
住飯店的時候想說
這飯店一碗一萬
再加上吃的
算他一万五好了
假设我每天我的现金流
有到一万五的话
我是不是应该就退隐江湖了
退隐江湖了
不是毕竟住饭店也就很爽了嘛
然后该买的保险保一保
好像就差不多了
人生好像太大花费
好像也没有
反正你也不可能天主饭店
那假如有一天不住饭店
你可能就省下一万五
省下一万五了
可能就比较好
哦
那
這個存美
存
存債券我覺得會比存股票來的好
哦 因為股票呢會有這個多空循環的問題而且有些股票呢它的壽命是有一定的各位你可以去看
20年前的台股
20年前台股呢
有很多股票都已經下市
很多股票下市
所以很難說你今天買的股票
到了10年後
它到底會不會下市
那我們這種買債券ETF的
至少它會
標的名單嘛
那當然你還是得付他一點經理費嘛
那我相信很多KOL很多網紅
對買這種ETF的不屑一顧啦
他說自己買就好了買什麼ETF
我是覺得買ETF至少它的流動性比較好嘛
假設有一天我要用錢
我要用一天
假設有一天我要用一天的錢就好
一天
我用一天的錢
我可以在盤中很快速的
我可以把
我可以把我的
這個
的ETF我可以直接把它賣掉
你自己看喔
3.1是3.15
這中間差了0.01
0.01是非常非常小
一般股票都是3.1
或是3.1
3.15
1XX0.05
可是他們這個TIG是1XX0.01
所以他的TIG很小
他的TIG很小
那TIG很小呢
很小呢 他一賣
你看我一下子一賣
我到那盤一下我就可以倒掉1000張
那1000張你就可以變現3000萬
你可以變現3000萬
對不對
所以呢 我看中他
可以很快速變現的能力
那你單獨自己買債券的話
我覺得會有一個缺乏變現能力
我就比較麻煩
好啦 你們今天不是要講美債
我只是剛好今天這個拿到再寫了
跟各位分享一下
好
來
這裡
這邊是這個選擇對樣單
那這是我對樣單啦
有興趣呢也歡迎各位看一下
好
那樂透呢上個月有開喔
這個月
我覺得開就可能蠻高的
下禮拜三又要樂透了
有興趣的
你可以去看一下下禮拜三
你可以去看一下
2021年的影片
2021年影片
好
那
这个我们做当初呢
我们最重要的就是要看这个买卫盘捷径那买卫盘捷径这个买买盤捷径呢我们会从这里看
看连次量
看连次量排序
那连次量爆针的话
两个都亮灯的话
其他两个都亮灯
那你等到变成绿灯
两次大概就是捷径
大概一次
大概就那时候捷径
啊那
呃急殺呢賣盤捷徑好他會出現這種連次亮亮燈
很大時候
那我每天呢我就會
呃用當中神奇的電腦版來做
那每天我就找到一堆
股票用連次排序
那這個連次呢月到上面的
這邊呢是準備要放空的
股票
那绿色呢就是一直往下杀的
那是准备要回补的股票
所以呢我们会盘中抓点捷径
再利用这个
连吃量的排序来做
那连吃量排序来做
我们就会
比较容易抓到这种买卖盘捷径点
各位你看这就是一些买卖盘捷径点
富巧之前买卖盘捷径
你看我的补的点其实都蛮漂亮的
這個急殺的回補點
這個裡面有補到漂亮
急拉的空點
殺的買點
拉的空點
這邊都有補到 你看這個點都有補到
那這些呢 它都會出現在那個轉折的位置
所以呢 你利用這些 你就可以來做一些短線的
這個當充
短線當充 我們就是來抓轉折
那抓轉折呢 我們就會去找那種
呃 這個
呃 標的來做啦
喔 照葛日聰的標的來做
那葛聰定義是這樣子喔
這個今天買
喔 那大概率明天賣
大概率啦
那大概率
我們不能跟你講
他一定明天賣
我只能跟你講他大概率
喔
有可能明天賣
我不保證的啦
喔 很多人
還會失去我
小哥為什麼他今天不賣
我問我怎麼知道
他不賣 你還問我
你應該問他吧
你問我 我怎麼知道不賣
他凹單啊 他心情不好啊
我嫌賺太少啊 對不對
我也不曉得為什麼
曲衣金鼎
這個地方不賣
我怎麼知道
我連他是誰我都不知道了 好不好
我連他是誰我都不知道
幹嘛這一天不賣
群衣經典
這個有在線上
請你發個聲音好不好
群衣經典
有在線上的
發個聲音可以嗎
好不好
讓我知道一下
為什麼你今天不賣
為什麼你這天不賣
你這天賣我就賺帆
你幹嘛不賣
對不對
因為這一天我已經
準備下重手了
因為這一天空的勝率是超高
跟各位講
群衣經典假如在這一天喔
就是
我現在畫這個點啦
齁 群經理假如在這一天大賣的話
喔 那一天我就賺反
呃 有債喊債 對不對
群經理債喊債
好不好 債喊債
呵呵 你幹嘛不在那邊賣
齁 你連鎖兩天了 好不好
你連鎖兩天了 這天幹嘛不賣
對不對 我們來看一下 他這邊買7000
我們來看這兩天齁
來來來 看這兩天
看兩天就好
你看啊 你看群衣精靈
呃 在這位置
在這位置兩天
唉呦 不讓我移過去 討厭
我用這裡
欸 他兩天15.36
然後損印740萬 8000張欸
然後拉到這裡17.1
不要說17.1了 讓他賣在
16.3就好 好不好
賣在16.3就好
讓他一張賺一塊就好
8000張 隨便賺也800萬
對不對 也800萬啊
我讓你賣16.3欸 都賣得很差了
最高17.1 我讓你賣16.3
你也賺800萬欸
結果800萬不賺 趕快去賠2000
幹嘛不賣 賣賣多好
哈哈
對不對 賣賣這個當天大腸黑多少
我哪知道他不賣
不賣後面整個跌下來
所以賣不賣要問他好不好
搞不好他不會送啊 對不對
他搞不好下單的時候想說
哎呀今天我賣的可能爽到小哥
我不想
我不想讓小哥爽我不賣了
結果他不賣他就沒跌
沒跌後面就
那後來我看到他的盤中跌是沒有那麼高我有些股票在那裡我看到他的盤中跌勢沒有那麼高我有些股票我就直接
融券流倉
所以融券有的流到快回到月線我才補掉
他不賣我就不要全部補
他假如賣賣 跌下我就補
賣賣我有賺我就補嘛
他不賣 我覺得賺太少不補
等到後面補
結果等到後面補賺更多
所以有時候我們研究籌碼
有時候會想 這個人幹嘛不賣
很奇怪
賣了你賺我也賺不是很好嗎
對不對 你賺錢我也賺錢
大家都開心啊 對不對
結果搞到沒賣 搞到後面
我是賺得有點痛苦啦
因為我真的不大喜歡農券流娼
我不喜歡啦 我不喜歡
不喜歡農券流娼
因為流娼農券我覺得
被嘎的機率高
我就不喜歡
結果流倉之後
反而賺更多
好
格衝第一仗喔
那第二個呢
他會買在靠近掌停板的位置
靠近掌停板的位置
才是格衝喔
沒有掌停板位置
不是格衝
好
Newham說
他想放中琴
才不是好不好
想放中琴
那現在幹嘛賣
你告訴我
為什麼想放中期
然後賣到現在 為什麼
就是那天沒有賣嘛
那天賭氣嘛
賭氣不賣
搞到後面賣後面那就很可惜
小哥有沒有化身過隔衝主義去說
沒有
沒有那個卡通不要吃那個下油
沒有那個卡通
隔衝很恐怖的
隔衝有時候一鎖
隔聰有时候一锁一赔
就是几千万起跳
隔聰赚的钱也是辛苦钱
那一天叫我赔几千万
我可能会睡得不好
所以我不干这种事
不干这种事
宁愿赔钱不让小哥爽
对
这个最近很多隔聰都变隔聰
大多争很熟
对很多隔聰都变隔聰
所以你不要因為隔衝去空股票
再講一次喔
不要因為隔衝空股票
所以我們今天特別舉了幾個案例
舉個案例 合一哇 你看一下 這夠隔日沖了吧只會買兩千張買4億喔 那今天呢
欸 再賣兩千張 再賣4億
喔 夠隔日沖了吧
你看到他 你去空
喔 你看到凱基
隔日沖 你去空
你去空 各位看一下
喔 那個結果呢
結果是不大好的喔
各位你看一下
這合一啊 我們來看一下合一這裡
你空合一齁 還好 我今天連做合一我都沒做
沒有 完全沒做
因為基本上這種線型我是不想做的啦
這個不要因為有格衝你就去空人家啦 再講一次
而且這種剛開布林的齁 開布林嚴上軌 阻頭買齁
放棄
連放在自選股都沒放在自選股
連放一支旋鼓都沒放一支旋鼓
而且你看昨天人家鎖的多漂亮
鎖的很漂亮啊
所以這種
不想做
所以呢這種隔日沖喔
不要
呃不要
空的時候要小心啦
阿假如是
呃過了很多天
喔
呃過了很多天你真的要空
可能好一點
喔 這個你過了很多天
這個拉了很多天之後去空喔
可能會稍微好一點啦
4128這裡
你看他昨天也是很多歌衝
原賦
這很賣啊
結果你看一下這個
中天間長什麼樣子
你看一下你假如去空中天喔
你看他昨天這兩檔都很強啦
你空他你找還沒補到
沒補到後面拉起來
嘎的不要不要的
對不對
所以
隔衝的股票不是沒檔
你都能空的喔
你要有所過濾喔
有所過濾
那我們現在的軟體已經很方便了齁
已經幫各位很快速的
這個過濾到一些股票了
我是覺得還不錯啦
就是他很快速的幫你找到一些
這個隔日沖的標的
看一下來來來,誒這是今天隔日沖的標的來這裡
好
那我們的
欸 各位有沒有看到
這就是今天
有隔日沖的標的
那有的有漲停
有的是曾經漲停
那曾經漲停呢他會幫你算一下隔日沖的占比
喔 隔衝贊品 那隔衝贊品呢
他就會算 那個
呃
買超在
這個掌停板附近的喔
他會去大概評估一下
他的隔衝的
比例是多少
張 比例是多少張
那這幾檔呢 我們來看一下齁
那這一檔呢 各位你要做之前齁
你一定要再打開籌碼開線
自己再過濾一下
齁 欸 要
沖之前自己過濾一下啦
自己過濾一下
看一下他的型態啊
主要我是覺得你要看一下型態
看一下型態
然後看一下買超的分點
來來來來看一下喔
像今天是這個
華泰嘛
華泰這個開布林喔
那今天主要是自行商買
自行商買感覺還好
假如投信買你可能要避開一下
那我們要看的是喔
今天買超
哇這個華奈今天有好多歌聰去鎖喔
這個凱基明天應該是會出貨啦
原副明天應該會出貨
這檔明天的波動很大
那你可以一檔一檔看一看
第一個你要看一下他的型態啦
唉呦這個生權喔
這生權好像想要挑戰開步林的樣子喔
那明天也是群衣精鼎
這個凱基喔這兩個應該是
也是手牽手來
手牽手一起鎖嘛 對不對
他們兩個來看一下主要是誰鎖的
主要應該是群衣經理鎖的
群衣經理鎖的
那凱立台北 凱立城中 撲邦 國票安和
都有鎖 這些都是隔衝
隔衝很簡單分辨啦
就只買在漲停板的
就隔衝
那隔衝我們都講就是渣男嘛
渣男就是一夜請的
一夜勤的
小時候不理你
等到有一天你成人的
立馬怎麼樣
立馬鎖長停
隔天就拋棄
那這個
比較純情的是長這樣
比較純潔的像這
國標頓北法人也算不錯啦
至少在這個讀小學 讀國中 讀高中
讀大學 至少都有聯絡 對不對
從小聯絡到大
這就是比較好的啦
那這樣 撲邦板橋是
小時候都有聯絡 漲停板賣一些
那這個就不一定隔衝
這個我們要看的隔衝就會看
是不是只有
只碰
掌停板
只碰掌停板
就會比較
比較有可能隔衝
大概是這樣分辨
那這個隔衝隔天波動大
這跟各位講我們只能保證他波動大
我不能保證他黑K
只能保證他波動大
不能保證他黑K
然後有些隔衝標的
你不要講
像我們今天直播講
那些格子聰的主力會不會看
他也會看啊
打開直播看啊
又小哥今天講到我的股票喔
明天不爽
不爽出啦
明天不爽出
不爽出他就不吃格子聰
但他波動還是大
他不會說沒波動
波動還是很大
因為A格子聰不爽出
可能B格子聰就落跑了
他波動還是大
一定都是大波股
大波谷
所以這種大波谷
就是蠻好玩的
就是
你用刀宋神器來玩
來看
你就可以找到一些
至少你可以找到波動大的股票
那我們剛剛給各位看
就是
你看一下
波動大
這個台股
我們現在看
來
我現在呢
這個
過濾給各位看
設定
我們先顯示檔數啦
可以當充的1780檔
當然這邊有一些
這個ETF啦
ETF通常是不愛當充
來 我們政府的齁
來 設定資料篩選條件齁
我大於
大於5%好了
給各位看喔 剩幾檔
大於5%剩下91檔
就1700檔齁
7,700檔
大於5%的剩下91檔
那我跟各位講明天啊明天這檔 給各位看這邊這個葛聰
這個華泰亞生權
只要沒有鎖漲停
再講一下喔 只要沒有鎖漲停
因為鎖漲停
他就沒波動了
只要沒有鎖漲停
那麼他的明天的政府
超過5%機率非常高
我只能跟你講他超過5%機率很高
所以你要這個做短充的
你要做短多短空都可以
隨便你
因為反正要波動大嘛
你要做短多短空都可以
這個反正你去抓轉折都可以
短多短空都可以
就是你要上下起走都可以
他至少是一個
比較適合做當充的標的
這隔充呢他一定是適合
比較可以做當充的標的
所以呢
你可以利用當充神器來抓轉折
你可以利用當沖神器來抓轉折
我沒有說你一定要去空它
或者去買它
沒有
但是呢
一定很容易用神器來抓轉折
抓轉折來做
就會很好做
好
那有格子沖的股票
有沒有可能
隔天又漲停呢
那當然有啊
這個我們看過很多啊
就是格子沖股票
隔天又漲停
當然有喔
就是
他可能前一天他已經鎖得很漂亮了
欸 有人問他華裔
你看這種
呃 尤其這種很低檔的喔
這算整理很久
整理很久的D跟隔天泥
就 當然 千萬你連碰都不要碰
當然不要空他啦
空他這種是
空他這種是更危險啦
這種是絕對也不會碰
這種幾乎也沒亮
那103張
這沒什麼好玩的
喔 這個量太少
這種漲停板也不會去玩它
喔 不管它有沒有當充
看到103張
不夠玩啦
這個 張數太少了喔
這不會去碰它
喔
好
所以呢
隔衝就這樣
隔衝呢 它會讓你
找當充的股票呢 會
很好找
隔天你要做多做空都可以
但是
你要記得隔天呢 很容易
買盤捷徑跟賣盤捷徑
隔天的轉折會比較好抓
比較好抓
好來 各位有興趣喔 你可以來看我的交易筆記本每天呢我們都會寫那個當充的標的啦當充的標記呢裡面就有一些這個當充的一些這個
標的啊 標的看我當充的
為什麼去充他都會有一些理由
那我們的流存率很高
那加入抽碼可以出完專欄呢
這個可以了解這個大家的看的標的
那我們最後呢 工商一下
雙十一會 十點半開搶
前五名購買 直接免費上課
這個十點半就搶了喔
過半小時就搶了
過半小時
十點半
11月9號
開搶
十點半
十點半就開搶了
看一下
這個俊宇齁是明天的十點半嘛
是明天的10點半嘛
俊宇俊宇
明天10點半喔
沒錯喔
喔我看一下
他這寫
喔今天晚上啦
今天晚上不是明天啊
今天晚上10點半就開牆了
因為他這個是
本來是寫11月9號的凌晨嘛
喔怕大家太晚睡
我們是今天晚上10點半開牆
前五名購買呢
直接獲得免費上課的資格
哇他就值了快4千塊了嘛
只快4000塊
然後呢這個
活動結束後再抽5名
講座半價折價券通通有獎
面額是1944元3張
那這個去年前年買的用戶
今年續訂成功也會額外再抽5名
去年前年你有買的
因為有人專門買雙11啊
這個也會額外再抽5名
那優惠二呢
我們有這個日復一日
利 喔 那這個要特別講一下
這個是做賠錢的
來給各位看一下
好
欸 給各位看日富一日利喔
這個是賠錢的啦
賠錢的一個東西
來看一下來看一下
因為第一個他們第一年做
沒有經驗
所以呢做的蠻好看的
盒子
盒子就很高貴
來
然後呢 出來
這個
第一頁呢
第一頁這個後面呢 還會改因為我這個是樣本第一頁還會改那這是日曆給各位看 它是日曆喔日曆
所以呢它會有 每天呢會有一些
一些小故事喔
因為它是個日曆
每天一句
每天呢會有一些
這個我的一些
景言家具
那還有一些市場上的一些事件
每天都會有
然後呢是日曆
然後各位啊你看
像這個鐵環啊
裡面的內容啊
反正做一做呢
這個小明星就跟我講齁
他們做這個都是
賠錢賣的
第一個他們量也做不大
只做一千份
也不會再增加
就是那麼一千份
重點呢我們還會送
全套軟體專業版15天
那這個值2000塊
你假如有在用軟體
我是覺得
你有在用軟體就很值得啦
因為它2000嘛
值2000
你有折價券用一用
你大概花不到1000
你又可以得到這個軟體2000
然後你的日曆呢
你可以拿回去收藏
我覺得還不錯啦
限量的
出版就絕版
對
然後
明年會不會做
不知道
因為他們今年做到賠錢
我就不知道明年會不會做
反正是做佛心來了
我說那你幹嘛不做做立
做立那個換一換就好了
你就不要花那麼重的成本
他們說第一次就想做漂亮一點
做得很漂亮
這阿了幾
好啦 就這樣
小秘書他們做出來的啦
好 那進一課程呢
我們有不理軌道多功課台北廠
台北廠禮拜天
禮拜天最後一場啦
那我們這裡還有付費直播
有興趣的歡迎報名參加啦
這個台中高雄場的反應還不錯
上完高雄場的課
高雄場是滿的喔
上完的時候呢
這個底下立馬有人上來問
下一次高雄場要上什麼
那我想說
那也等我的頸椎好一點
因為我現在的頸椎呢
不曉得這個之後會怎麼樣
因為我最近是繼續做復健
不然手會滿
我覺得是有點麻煩
有點麻煩
然後就奉勸各位
盤不要看太久
所以呢我以後我的下班妹子
可能會靠這些
那個
呃 ETF 的配型
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕